well good afternoon I'm George Van
Tamsin and I was that guy on the screen
talking about ghosts running around alma
mater and Lowe library have the great
privilege of having graduated from the
college in 1974 and the great honor to
by dint of the era of all of the proxies
and you guys raising your hand to be the
new chair of CAA and
so I will tell you and you probably
heard me say this before this is really
an exciting time I mean I'm just really
excited and thrilled to be following two
leaders of the CIA Steve Case the first
chair who did so much to articulate
articulate the goals and the mission of
CAA and its importance to Columbia and
all alumni under Jim hardens leadership
CAA became even more relevant and even
bigger and more successful than we had
envisioned a real collaborative effort
with all the schools of the University a
means of collect of connecting
collecting and connecting alumni with
Columbia's intellectual ferment and its
spirit and its passion it's a network of
incredible power personal and
professional resource and a community
that
invigorates us all as a group and
individually I just want to take a
moment to thank the staff and the
leadership Donna McPhee and her team
Fred Van Sickle Susan Fagan all of the
people involved with helping to generate
this but most importantly all of the
alumni leaders around the world who make
this what it is and what it should be
but I want to especially thank Jim
Hardin today for the work that he has
done and asked Donna to come up
to offer him a small token of our esteem
and thanks for his service it's not even
close to what we should be doing for Jim
his involvement with the CAA was
enormous a chair for four years and I
assure you this chair will not be in a
chair for four years but now that he's
moved on trustee of the University we
plan to call on him we plan to use him
not too often we clearly need his keen
understanding his gentle style and his
good humor where is Jim did he leave
Jim
please accept our thanks and our
heartfelt admiration for all you do have
done and will continue to do for CA
so let us continue with our afternoon
I'm pleased to announce this is really
funny I love doing this this is great
I'm pleased to announce president Li si
Bollinger and the chair two trustees
Bill Campbell now Donna insisted that I
play this straight
I'm struggling here Frank but I'll play
it straight in all seriousness we're
proud to have president Bollinger here
with us it's a testament to the
importance that he views this entire
effort his time his talent the treasure
of this university goes into this
enterprise a great intellect a man of
strong sense of principles and an
undeniable moral compass and a
willingness to have difficult
conversations in fact I think he's
become quite skilled at having difficult
conversations not of his own design and
he's an alum of the law school above
wall he gives us a vision for Columbia
that will lift us to new heights we've
all been pleased to see that the
university is ranked highly in the media
that's a testament to the powerful
administration that supports our schools
and the university as a whole now you
should know that president Bollinger and
the trustees initiated a strategic
planning exercise called CAA 2017 to
create a five-year strategic plan for
CAA in conjunction with CAA and
stakeholders throughout the university a
Presidential Task Force will be formed
to work on this plan it's an exciting
really exciting time for CAA and we are
quite frankly ready to go to the next
level so president Bollinger thank you
I'm also pleased to announce I'm also
pleased to announce my very good friend
and chair of the trustees Bill Campbell
bill has had a long experience with
it says that he earned his BA from
Columbia majoring in economics in 1962 I
would ask the President to form a
investigative committee as to if that
actually occurred this captain of the
football team when he was here and he
was a guard I think he weighed 165
pounds as a guard but I certainly would
take him now
earned his master's degree from Columbia
in 1964 he served as coach at Columbia
his love for Colombia is astronomical
and his understanding of the community
is impressive and he has had an
impressive career not only at Columbia
but in business enormous success in the
world of technology having been an
executive at Apple Computer founder of
klaris president and CEO of Intuit
chairman of Intuit known as the coach of
Silicon Valley role that he takes
seriously but does not seek publicity
currently he's a director of the
National Football Foundation College
Hall of Fame which allows them to get a
lot of free tickets to good games serves
on the board of directors the Apple and
Intuit and continues most importantly to
guide Columbia into the future our own
bill Campbell please welcome president
Bollinger and Bill Campbell